[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a 113.
yes yeah there it is okay um
so we're gonna we're gonna hard cap in
an hour today um
so that zach can catch his plane
yes yeah
from the discord this week again um
one of the uh one of the perks of
joining either of our patreons is that
you get access to the discord and then
every week they
um vote on a question to ask which we
start off the q a with i should say that
in the main livestream occasionally
yeah
um humans the question begins are very
good at recognizing faces however when
encountered with a vastly different race
from our own
did the catches put his paw on the water
no but he did think about it yeah okay
i'm going to start over
this this this chord question this week
humans are very good at recognizing
faces however when encountered with a
vastly different race from our own
everyone seems to look very similar and
we have a hard time differencing them
from each other could this be a possibly
sinister evolutionary trait to more
easily other them in case of a hostile
encounter
uh yeah it can be uh or could be but i
would say that that is it's like
downstream not the most likely thing
going on here yeah what i would say is
the most likely thing going on here and
this is a testable hypothesis
is that people tend to be grouped for
various reasons by race and because of
that
what it means is that your developmental
experience at recognizing subtleties of
faces is going to be biased in the
direction of those you were around so
what you would expect if this was true
the prediction of the hypothesis
is that if you are a person who is a
minority raised in a group of people of
some different race that you will
actually have high acuity for their
faces
and a longitudinal study which probably
can't be done because the earlier data
weren't taken
would be controlling for country
controlling for space
as we become a more global culture
people have um less of this inability
they have an increased ability
to recognize people uh who look wildly
different from themselves as effectively
they are being exposed to many different
types of people and faces in their early
developmental environment right
now i would i would suggest that there's
another realm in which we can see the
same
sort of pattern play out in which the
answers are much more obvious
which is language
right so you will notice that i am
speaking english i had noticed that well
done thank you despite having zero
english ancestry yeah i did a little bit
maybe you learned it from me it's
possible i did that seems unlikely
though yeah but on account of when we
met you were already speaking english
yeah falsified i anticipated
and prepared
um but you definitely didn't learn it
from me no that's true yeah i learned it
for you
all right um my point though
is
i have really good acuity in english
right like the subtleties that i can
detect in english are
pretty extraordinary my acuity in
lithuanian
is
zero and yet and yet you didn't pick
lithuanian out of a hat
uh you do have some ancestral stuff in
in that part of the world well that part
of the world none from lithuania itself
but but anyway my political area yeah my
point is
and actually i have long wondered there
are certain instances in which an
immigrant obviously a highly intelligent
immigrant is in my opinion taken in by a
transparent
uh
con artist let's say okay and my thought
has always been i wonder if you're in
your second language
if the subtleties that might cause
somebody for whom it was their first
language to think that
doesn't mean that's not quite right yeah
that's just harder to detect and so that
if you were basically
more likely to be taken in
in a in a foreign language even one that
you're perfectly fluent in
um so anyway what i would say is
you could argue and i do actually
believe that language um that there's an
evolutionary story that is true about
language in which
you know we think language's purpose is
to communicate no
language's purpose is to communicate to
those you want to understand what you're
saying and to avoid communicating to
those who you would rather not know what
you're saying and that the divergence of
language has much to do with this i
believe is likely but
um and then there there are reasons to
think that in the phylogeny of language
but
yeah they've got this there's a there's
a lot here right and there i mean you
see this even at the level of
non-language communication in other
animals where single single types of
vocalizations
uh will both be sort of come hither
calls to females and stay the [ __ ] away
uh indicators to to males right
single things
can have multiple divergent adaptive
effects so i first had this thought uh
when i was doing
my first field gig in jamaica um you and
i were already together so you well know
all of this and
you know know that i was thinking about
this when i came back but the point is
my experience living in jamaica and i
was living way the hell off in
backcountry jamaica with the jamaican
family
you were bob trevor's assistant yep they
took me in as their own they fed me
housed me i became friends with the
people who were my age kids followed me
around anyway it was a really
interesting experience
but i was always struck by the fact that
if i was walking alone at night you know
on one of these country lanes dark back
country jamaica no overhead lights
anything like this
you couldn't exactly see who you were
encountering right the difficulty at
understanding what was being conveyed
was extreme and for you right because
right for them
not at all
but the point was there are certain
subtleties like the fact that yes can
mean no
right um which i yeah man
i thought at the time
like
wouldn't an enslaved culture have come
up with ways to speak such that the
slave holders would have no idea what
was being conveyed i mean obviously you
could right of course and so you know me
having the queen's english and therefore
effectively you know
a schooling in the slaveholders language
which they also understood because there
was television right so they were
hearing the queen's english all the time
right but it wasn't the english that
they were mostly and they were learning
in school right the queen's english is
taught in school um and so yes they're
absolutely fluent in in my language and
their language is a struggle for me and
contains all of these things that are
like
almost perfectly ironic in versions of a
meaning
um
and anyway it occurred to me at the time
that this was something you would you
would expect a population that had
reason to need to speak in secret would
come up with uh effectively a code that
would become
uh
you know
a native language to them and would be
just difficult to parse and impossible
to prove and
and all of that absolutely um on a
related but actually totally different
topic can you remind me
uh what was meant uh when your jamaican
friend said rat and ratbat
yeah um
or tell tell our audience it was bat and
rat bat
[Music]
yeah so bat
means moth
and rat bat means bat
um there it is yeah i actually i said
remind because i was like rat and rap
bat how do you get there but now it's
bat and rat bat it was bad that means
moth
yes which it actually makes a kind of
sense
and there's also a giant moth in jamaica
yeah you know if you're not paying real
close attention does sort of seem like a
bat has flown by and if you i mean if
for anyone who's watching who spent any
time actually watching
roland animals that is flying animals
high on the wing maybe swifts and
swallows can be confused for bats but if
you know what time of day you're looking
at them you know generally not so much
but if you're at all close to them
most birds and bats just do not fly in
the same way at all and if you're close
to them the way that a bat
will
move around a cluttered environment is
very much
um
it is more similar to the way that a
moth does than um that a bird does yeah
at least for at least for bats that are
clutter specialists right
yeah
and which is a lot of the bats that we
encounter right these little hawking
insecticides like understory bats
effectively yeah there are some bats
that are you know long-distance uh
efficient
flyers who have a different pattern but
anyway yeah it is it is this thing but
there were a number of these in in
jamaica where something where there was
a language swap like um
avocado
was pear
which i thought was interesting i mean
the reason for it was pretty obvious and
there and there were no actual pairs i
certainly didn't encounter it and you
wouldn't remember it's pretty temperate
it's pretty temperature expected
um
and let's see
there's something even just with the
fruits like the sweet sop and soursop or
is that just
um
no i think sweet swap and soursop were
boy it's been so long i've forgotten
some of these things but um yeah there
were a number of these where some some
word had been swapped in and uh
anyway
cool interesting
okay going to the questions that have
been asked in the q a at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
what are your best and worst predictions
for the outcome of the pandemic is there
even the possibility of an end
do you think states like florida and
texas are safe from vaccine mandates etc
thank you so much you're the only ones i
trust hugs
um thank you for that we shouldn't be
the only ones you trust but we do
appreciate that we have earned your
trust and um
there are there are a lot of people who
are trying to make sense of all of this
and are not being um and are not being
dishonest uh when they change their
minds and um
are are trying to take in new data
insofar as it's available um but we
certainly count ourselves in that group
yeah and the real question is do you
have a toolkit
that's any good yeah are you
committed to using it which then forces
you to correct things if you get it
wrong right and are you
immune to
various kinds of pressures either
positive incentives or threats that
might persuade you
to sign up for
some other narrative and
surprising how few people you know have
all three of those but nonetheless there
is a small group of them
um so the question so i think i think
what is meant here is sort of most
hopeful and least hopeful predictions
best and worst predictions um because
you know we could we could play giving
really bad predictions but i don't think
that's what's being asked bad
predictions that are numerous yeah in
fact
infinite yeah just you know go go check
with the cdc
hey there you go um
um
yeah you know with regard to least
hopeful prediction for the outcome of
the pandemic the next question is there
even the possibility of an end well you
know the one of the least hopeful
predictions is that
um
this and the the creeping and sometimes
not so creeping totalitarianism uh is
here to stay and it's doing a job
and it's doing a job that that people
not us not the mass the vast majority of
us but some people want done and so we
are um we are stuck with it which is
part of why
i find so much hope in the truckers
convoy
and also part of you know but then you
know maybe to go to um
you know dire prediction again
literally nothing in the new york times
to the washington post not even a
mention right of what is a
extraordinarily large number of people
and disruption and activism aren't the
people the new york times and washington
post in favor of activism because i was
assured that they were and i was assured
in fact that when you poured out into
the streets to challenge white supremacy
then you were actually you were cloaked
in coveted safety like you couldn't get
the disease and it turns out it was the
being outside part the protected people
not so much the um they were in favor of
hashtag black lives matter etc um but
you know it all works yeah all right so
i want to divide the
um negative predictions into two because
you've said it maybe that the
totalitarianism [ __ ] is with us
permanently which i agree yeah is a
possibility now how that plays out i
think it could be it could um
recede and give us a breather and then
come up with a new excuse and in some
sense we can argue that you know the
patriot act was
round one and coveted
tyranny is round two and there's a lot
of this that feels like practice
yeah where it's it's incremental
right well but we're just
data are being collected on all of us
and how we are all responding and who
the troublemakers are
and uh and which people will fall in
line and become extremely useful
idiots uh to the powers that be and now
now a lot of that is known that wasn't
transparent before i mean we've all
learned a lot about who will fall which
ways and um those those are data that
are useful uh to anyone who wants to
control a population in the future
right there's what they know and there's
also what they've gained that just you
lose track of right i mean so um yes uh
the ndaa 2012 section 10 22 and 10 23 or
whatever it was um you know
when's the last time you heard that
right we don't talk now right that is i
guess technically yeah that would be the
last time but um busted but the point is
most of us are just exhausted and you
know so we don't talk about it that
frequently even though the point is you
know what it never went anywhere you
know i know you were you were going
somewhere specific but i just wanna an
aside for this this term exhausted
i used to rail
against people claiming i'm so tired i
just can't do my thing and you know
often it was the people who were doing
make work and not contributing anything
and we're so busy with all of these
things that if they just said no to the
world would not have collapsed in any
way and it just would have gone and done
it would have been fine and they could
have cleared their schedule if they
wanted to actually do important work the
fact is they didn't have important work
to do and that is part of why it's
useful to claim to be so exhausted all
the time and this exhausted thing
also emerged of course during um sort of
the woke revolution around you know
you know the emotional labor i just it's
not my job to explain to you how
exhausted i am um and yet what this has
done is effectively isolated and
actually exhausted us so you know
all of us at some level
such that we cannot even
remember fully and this is part of where
you're going we can't even fully
remember what we had and what kinds of
ways we had of being in the world
and we've just
it's like it's it's given us all like
ssris it's like flattened our affect
right we have lost the ability to have
it capture our attention and convince us
that there's some i mean
except for those of us who are unvaxxed
and who are constantly being like you
know oh you can't go in there you can't
go in there you can't do this and so
you know the the people who are
vaccinated but just kind of over it um
are increasingly acting like you know
drugged just okay let me get back to i
remember that i used to do stuff i don't
really remember what it was but you know
i know i liked parties that sort of
thing
and um and there are some of us kind of
like it's still going on it's getting
worse well it's still going on but my
point is the covet thing is still going
on yeah
you mean the public the policy responses
and such right yeah whatever that you
know you've got covid you've got a
pathogen and you've got tyranny riding
on that carrier yes as you said last
week yes right and so that's still
happening but i also know you know years
ago how many years ago i couldn't even
tell you
brilliant presentation
by i think he was a graduate student he
might have been a postdoc computer
scientist who demonstrated in a live
presentation
that there was a way that you could
capture a network printer i believe it
was hp network printers were the most
vulnerable but it was a widespread
vulnerability that you could get
somebody to print a document and in that
document was effectively a
a
bit of malware that captured the network
interface and then basically left your
printer as a vulnerability in any
network that could be accessed right
now
have you ever heard that before from you
from me yeah
that's that's it right so the point is i
you know but i don't i don't yet see the
connection to what i mean it's
horrifying but i don't see the
connection to what we were talking about
was the problem ever cured
with regard to uh networked printers and
by networked printers you don't mean
you're in an office and it's not worked
other printers you you mean in your home
where you've got a wi-fi network and you
want it i mean a printer that is on your
network with your other computers that
is now accessible to the outside world
because it has right but i feel like
that's that's that's the clarification i
was making when you say
networked you're not talking about
an inherently a large office space
you're talking about your private
printer at home
um if you've got it um just
just being able to print wirelessly
right it doesn't even have to be
wireless right it can be your ethernet
connection
um but the point is your network can be
your computer and your printer or your
network feel like that was not what you
had said back in the day when you told
me that the point is it's just the
interface in the printer and whether or
not the printer has encountered okay
this thing and the point is there was at
the point that this was demonstrated
there was no way to deal with it you
couldn't do a firmware update and
restore your printer it was just cooked
it was a permanent vulnerability
almost nobody discussed this
i have no idea what happened to it so
the point is well does that mean that
whatever
engineered that vulnerability in there
has access to arbitrarily networks
across everywhere i mean so the point is
okay we've just forgotten that and i go
around talking to people about you know
is your network printer safe and they're
like i don't know you know what you're
talking about right um and how many of
those are how many of us remember that
uh you know in the
madness after you know the patriot act
that there were actually
governmental operations intercepting
laptops and things that you had ordered
from somewhere and modifying the
hardware in real time and delivering
them as if nothing had happened right
you could order a laptop and the laptop
had been altered by who knows what that
wanted access to your data and swore
that you were you know a risk are you
sure that's a known thing of course
and the point is we've all forgotten
well i just i don't i
i would like
i don't know i don't know that one right
of course well
no not there are a lot of things you
could say that you could say of course
and don't turn out to be true my point
is we've forgotten these things they
were discussed there are things there
are a lot of things that we've forgotten
and i because i know you
i assume that you are remembering this
correctly but you can't get in the habit
of just saying well of course you know i
just said and you've forgotten it and
that's evidence it's been forgotten
that's not evidence that it's been
forgotten
mean obviously if it's not true it's not
true but um but my point is i could come
up with a dozen of these things that
were of fundamental importance right the
fact that you used to be able to click a
switch on google and look at a global
search and then it disappeared yes right
these things happen they briefly capture
people's attention and a bunch of us go
wait don't you see what that might do
and then
we it disappears even from our memories
so to the example from google that you
just gave i think this gets back to the
point i believe you were originally
trying to make around
um
we have incremental losses of freedom
that we forget we ever had right okay
and so the point is
this particular iteration surrounding
covid
will have created inroads some of them
we may not even know because the whole
point may be well we secretly need to
track the you know right the
unvaccinated or no it will be
anti-vaxxer they will use that and the
point is that will put us on some list
and you know then who knows what it is
that that means that they have the right
to you know
to monitor us for yeah right forever
after and so the point is you see the
incremental thing where it you know it
crosses into the the liminal space and
you're aware that something is happening
and then it disappears from the liminal
space and you don't know what it's doing
and then it pops up again yeah and this
one happens to be the coveted version of
that but there's some ongoing thing
where we keep losing our privacy
right incidentally
this is exactly what uh
bobby kennedy was
trying to say at the mandate march and
it was uh you know he has been strawman
into
an absurd state by nearly everyone by
nearly everyone but
but the point is okay we've got the
tyranny side and then there's the
question about what's the bad what's the
negative
part you know prediction for the
pandemic itself
a
these sons of [ __ ]
bought
the opportunity that we had to drive
this thing extinct assuming that the
story of its origin is something like
what we now think it is
it's possible that it emerged much
earlier that it was endemic in animals
there's weird stuff there's point that
any of us have heard of it was never
possible to get rid of that right it's
possible that the deer and the mice
um preceded the human thing in which
case who knows but
but if the story is anything like we are
told it is even now that there is
grudging acknowledgement that a
laboratory leak is likely many of us
would say essentially certain at this
point oh but wait didn't this week
card-carrying molecular virologists
claim that it was likely zoonotic
according to and that was the phrase
that voucher used card-carrying
molecular virologists i love the idea
that we're going to start issuing cards
to molecular virologists to figure out
whether we should listen to them
i'm sorry before you speak can you show
us your credentials sir
right
um here's what i want to know okay so
there are card carrying uh molecular
virologists um what are the other
virologists made out of
made out of if not molecules
oh you see oh yeah yeah right oh well
okay so what do you do when a molecular
virulence meets a cellular virologist
um
uh
the scales fall from there i don't know
something yeah something okay um but
anyway so this is we're still in
question one here yeah all right so
let's just and we haven't done any most
hopefully let's just finish this tucker
yep
the bad version of the pandemic thing is
that it is endemic and it continues to
evolve in weird ways that we don't
necessarily anticipate because it being
a franken virus as you put it
is not obligated to follow rules of
thumb that we think we've learned about
other viruses and it keeps popping up or
it gives people excuses
to claim that something requires our
immediate attention and vaccination or
whatever they're going to do yeah so so
many things to be scared uh scared of
scared of scared of
i thought you were headed to spanish but
somebody just went irish
but uh okay so on the positive side
oh
one more thing not the tyranny exactly
but the scramble for the middle ground
also creates a dire potential here yes
it facilitates the the tyranny right the
spread of the tyranny right now
and the people who are scrambling for
the middle ground
would never imagine that that's what
they were facilitating i don't
i i don't think they're i think they're
thinking about their own well-being and
they're so obsessed with it that they
will
they will do this if given the
opportunity and um we will watch them
because
god damn it this cannot be allowed to
obscure the story of what actually
happened
but the point is there is also the
potential
for something marvelous to emerge out of
this on the human side if not the
pathology side
or the pathogen side on the human side
the discovery
that all of our institutions failed us
at the level of the construction of a
dangerous pathogen the
accidental release of the dangerous
pathogen
the
[Music]
let's just stay there
uh-oh
was bothering you um i just remembered
that it was bothering other people oh
we heard it see and i don't think i
fixed it
it's the thought that counts
yeah i think it's pretty fixed no it's a
little skewed i'm gonna go back to
saying what i was saying i did not i
really did not want you to pivot and put
me on screen zach doing that what
it's a small enough people who are
troubled by the
perpendicular-ness of that particular
object if you could just simply if it
doesn't look perpendicular to you and
it's bugging you could you just tilt
your screen so it does look
perpendicular that's not i don't so i
feel like i'm were i a viewer of the
show
and you know i don't know i'm not i
don't tend over into ocd territory
really but i feel like if i was looking
at us a long time and there was
something that was supposed to be
vertical between us and it was not quite
vertical and especially with all the
damn horizontal lines you put on the
wall back there
i mean you squared it right up and then
for something to be explicitly not
squared i could i could see it getting
to me
yeah all right um okay i really wanted
to just be able to do it off screen have
no one talk about it i think we failed
we came very close to you adjusting it
without anyone noticing oh okay okay
all right as you were
here's my point yes
the construction of the virus
the accidental hopefully release of the
virus the cover-up
the
botched public health response the
insane
vaccination campaign
all of that stuff has exposed
the
complete collapse of
our
governmental structures of the press
which isn't even
uh reporting on the convoy of the
academy yeah right
of big tech it is it is revealed if you
have eyes to see it has revealed the
collusion the trusted news news
initiative
gavi right the ways in which all of
these things are intermingled and they
have become
uh some kind of you know goliath or a
hydra i was just gonna say hydra yeah
so if we look at that and we say my god
look at the cost of covent
and look at what the systems that were
supposed to prevent this did they
actually caused it and then covered it
up and then lied and then
put the children at risk right
we have no choice
if we look that in the eye we have no
choice but to say well
this system is completely broken
what is the best shot we have at
restoring it right
yep so
i think the middle grounders are going
to
put a roadblock in that and they are
going to make it very hard for that to
occur and we have to get in the road of
the middle grounders so that we actually
have that conversation but if you want
to know what the upside is here is the
upside is that i sometimes say
certain stories diagnose the system yep
right the press was diagnosed by
the woke revolution it was diagnosed by
the evergreen story because certain
parts of the press wouldn't report it or
they would report it upside down yeah
right this is diagnosing the entire
system from academy through big tech yes
government public health all of it
and that lesson could be the moment at
which we wake up and say my god what
have we done to ourselves yeah um i will
say one of the things that i wanted to
talk about in the first hour um and this
is a good point good time just to insert
it here um so that it's been said zach
if you would show my screen this is just
this is
for my tweet of this guy then i want to
point out this guy's amazing thread so
i've said
uh so he wrote i s this is alex washburn
i see these institutions as unlikely to
reform because scientists with
undeserved power leading them stifle
competition unelected heads of agencies
underserved our democratic deliberations
by killing scientific debate with
hostile slogans of false consensus and
abuse of power
about which i said institutions like the
cdc and the nih which fund and drive
policy for so much of american science
have failed many scientists are alarmed
but not nearly enough what becomes a
society that forfeits science and gives
the reins to a few who crave power and
fame
this guy alex washburn um has written
quite a thread um
that begins as someone registered
democrat nine months before i was born
and a lifelong scientist son of a
scientist mom i've seen scientists
oversimplifying and demonizing competing
views
this culture of unscientific hostility
started at the top the heads of top fed
funding institutions he then just walks
through it and this is a young
former academic who's walked away from a
career in academic science because of
what he's seen during covet
increasingly people i'm hearing stories
like this now that means there are about
to be a whole lot of actually qualified
actual scientists who aren't working in
academia and are looking for work to do
what it doesn't mean
is that uh the the
the tight reigns uh that the nih and the
cdc and the nsf and dod and the who and
you know all the rest of them have on
who gets to do science um are going to
be loosened anytime soon so that needs
to happen well that needs to happen and
i would just say the fly in the ointment
is that unfortunately
the corrupt system we have
has
trained a large fraction of the people
who should be capable of doing good work
into something
uh sloppy and
very sensitive to
um incentives that have been used to
manipulate them and so unfortunately
there aren't as many good scientists
waiting to be freed from this as one
would hope
yeah but i think there might be more
than we yeah no there are more than we
know because lots of people are stuck in
a system that basically forces them to
to do this even though they would prefer
it yeah it didn't exactly
um we have two questions today that are
you know asking us to engage something
or someone that we've that we've
responded to in the past i'm gonna read
them out loud but um you know this
one apologies i may be butchering your
name
jean francois garippi is seeking a
friendly scientific discussion with you
please indulge my good friend ethan
ralph by going on his odyssey show to
speak with jfg consider please
so this is someone we've heard of he
sent us his book neither of us have
looked at it we've been involved in a
lot of other things and it's not that we
intend never to look at it but we are
not going to feel pressured by
such pleas yes and i would say i find
his followers strangely rabid and it
actually
creates more of an obstacle to wanting
to engage that material because i'm not
exactly sure what's causing that
phenomenon yeah that's true this
question doesn't sound that way i agree
but um but i but i agree in the past um
it has
it has not been
i don't like this phrase like a good
look it is it's
there's something charged there that
isn't about a simple scientific
discussion yeah um
so hold on the other one
that i wanted to say
um oh brett is this your explorer
mechanism
and it's this thing
um
cyclical metal population mechanism
hypothesis uh please show it briefly
um which you have ref you we have talked
about briefly before and i've said and i
don't think so this is not quite um what
you and we are on about um
and so we're not going to spend
it's hard for me to react to it because
from that
you know it's too vega title
you've looked at this before i remember
you looking at this before and i don't
remember in what show like where you
talked about it but um let's just say in
the past is when it happened oh well
that's not that useful is it
okay
um
given the dire state of affairs and how
systemic and entrenched many of the
issues are to what extent are
fundamental changes achievable do you
have a roadmap
love from japan
fundamental changes are achievable the
obstacle
is going to be
two things one
a short supply of people who have a
toolkit and um
values that will prevent them from being
captured and turned into tools they
exist but they don't exist in the kinds
of numbers that they would exist if you
had an honorable system
teaching people to
think and work right you have a system
that corrupts people and that corruption
goes right down to the fundamental
mechanisms of the mind and
so anyway
the
the
fixed system is going to be
a bit hard to staff until the system has
had time to generate a larger number of
people with the requisite skills
um
but the problem is
the the incentives surrounding and
a full thorough investigation of
what happened and how we got here i mean
how exactly are you going to address
the fact that you know the new york
times and the washington post
don't seem to report on major news
events that don't happen to
smile on the particular causes they've
signed up for right
what is that is this project mockingbird
just owns those two things and the point
is
you know we need
new newspapers you know
it's going to be hard to free a system
like this if lots of people
and you know it's painful but some of
our friends are among these people who
are just
itching to get back into a position in
you know in the elite institutions and
are unwilling to recognize
the complete collapse or the total
parasitism of those institutions by
forces that turn them ironic turn them
against their you know their stated
goals
the piece that i was working on for my
substance for next week that i'm going
to put off a little bit because i've got
a couple of um
letters uh
from people requesting exemption from
anyway i'm not going to talk about what
i'm about to post but um soon but not
immediately
i'm going to be writing exactly about
this the distinction between elite and
special as our friend rich de vinnie
who's a former navy seal officer
uh has described in an excellent essay
um basically arguing just one of the
theses of his of his of his piece which
is directed at other navy seals and
nebucial commanders
is
uh that
you know they are the special forces
and increasingly in the media and the
government they're referred to as elite
the elite team the elite soldiers the
elite units
and he argues that i am completely
compelled that he is right and this is
something that you and i have been
thinking about from a different place
you know coming from a totally different
place
um for for your decades like he has been
thinking about it from you know the
perspective of you know special ops um
is that elite is actually a lower bar
and uh elite also um trains you
indicates that you know how to deal with
something that isn't known
um and special is different and special
is therefore more powerful and should be
more scary to an enemy if you're you
know doing special ops or to
um you know to any kind of competitor if
you are just engaged in
a life of the mind and trying to figure
out what's true and trying to do you
know innovate technologically or
scientifically or artistically or
anything
that what you want is to be
special and you might also therefore be
elite the you know sort of thumbnail
description being that elite means
better special means different
and uh the idea that
wouldn't it be great if we could just
recover
uh our elite institutions and get back
to the way we were no
uh we we need a revolution that that
that
destroys
the kind of elitism that is exactly what
got us here into this mass
yep
i agree and you know the problem is well
that doesn't sound very likely no it
doesn't but in part it doesn't sound
very likely that we could accomplish the
goal because people have ignored it for
too long and some of us have been trying
to point out hey this is a problem your
your academic institutions are
completely parasitized by perverse
incentives that cause them to spit out
stuff that isn't science and the point
is that okay maybe now with covid we can
make that point and people will have
some idea what we're talking about but
the point is lots of people
usually lots of people still not
well lots of people still not and the
problem is um
we can't listen to those people this is
everything that happened downstream of
covet appears to be the result of a
self-inflicted wound
somebody a small set of somebodies
overrode a rule that said no gain of
function research right they overrode
that rule that rule was put in place to
protect us from exactly this thing
somebody overwrote it and they just so
happen to be the same somebody who is in
charge of figuring out what we do and
guess what they're not doing a good job
of that either in fact they're doing the
inverse of a good job yeah so you know
that tells you the job we have to to fix
it indeed okay let's try to get through
a few more questions um
fellow portlander here
um portland what are we called
portland eats
i think it's portlander portlander yeah
just says fellow pdx here um i want to
put flyers up to help spread data
centric info to help people wake up
would you suggest covid corruption facts
or something else to be most effective
that's really interesting and i would
love
i would love for you to
write to our moderator and get in touch
with um with me if you end up doing this
and you know
see what these flyers are and
and such um
but in terms of
you know coveted corruption vaccines
probably given
portland um
i would think that it would be either
corruption or mandates
um i'm i was
alarmed
actually yes yesterday was it that i was
walking around um eastside for a while
yesterday or two days ago it was
yesterday um i don't remember in the
last couple of days it's been really
beautiful here but very cold
so as long as you're dressed
appropriately really easy to walk around
it's not wet it's not icy or anything um
super dry super super blue skies um
but i was walking around a lot of um
southeast portland that i haven't spent
a lot of time in and i was amazed
at how
many places um
wouldn't let me in the door uh according
to the signs on the doors and in a
couple places i saw people checking the
the exports at the door
and that doesn't happen so much in um on
the west side um and i hadn't thought of
the river being this kind of dividing
line this is something we talked about a
fair bit um
just you and me last night um but so i
do think that it might that
the way to wake people up might be
different in different parts of the city
actually um that the parts of the city
that have been more likely to put up
don't hurt me
signs and flyers and you know fall
into the black lives matter stuff and um
the places where antifa is
you know are
are likely emerging from are more likely
to have um you know to be banning
unvaccinated people from restaurants and
and such um which is interesting right
like you i wouldn't necessarily have put
those things into the same group but
they seem to be
um and so if we can appeal to people's
sort of original
liberalism you know with the assumption
that portland is pretty pretty damn blue
um then um
posters against mandates and posters
that point out corruption seem to me to
be the places where people are most
likely to be reminded of their of their
roots and what they actually care about
when their values are
a couple things i was looking for a an
account there's a twitter account that
has cropped up in my awareness recently
that is
uh portland specific and
uh
it is um focused on all of the right
issues and i can't figure out is it rose
city outrage yeah i think it may be rose
city outrage
um in any case it's worth signing up for
it because i think it actually has its
finger on the pulse in some sense
i think that there's a lot of
but check it out rose city outrage you
might like coke industries
[Laughter]
cute yeah cute twitter they're so cute
so anyway here here's here's the point
you don't want to waste any time
trying to appeal to people who can't be
reached
and
i think there's a large group of people
that are
kind of into the power that comes from
certain aspects of this whether it's the
blm stuff or it's the coveted stuff
don't bother with them there are a lot
of people in portland
who
are aware
hey
somebody attacked our police and the
crime rate is going through the roof
right they're not happy about that
businesses yeah i wonder why shutting
down the homelessness problem is
absolutely out of control and there
appears to be no effort to do anything
useful people you know drag
uh abandoned cars and things
who did not abandon cars i mean car
theft is also through the roof well
right so there's all of these things
that any rational person living in
portland is pretty upset about at least
privately and if you want if you want to
make a dent i think pointing out hey the
city
functioned and now it functions less
well as a result of a lot of this
nonsense and uh that that that does
animate people and people frankly are
leaving for
completely understandable reasons yeah
okay um
the only way i see the narrative
surviving is for a new variant to appear
given the ambivalence regarding omicron
what are the chances
we just saw yesterday that there's some
scary new coronavirus variant that was
just found in china
well
let me say this you know your point
about the data stream is so
serious because the fact is who knows if
there is a new variant right if you're
going to take if you're going to
you know fire health care workers who
won't get vaccinated and then claim that
your health care system is overburdened
and then play games where people who
may or may not have a positive covet
test get filed as if they are in the
hospital for covid
right if you're gonna play all of these
games the point is oh when you don't
count as vaccinated until two weeks
after which means anything that happens
to you within two weeks of getting
vaccinated counts says oh often that's
actually we're gonna call that coven
right so
all of these games mean that actually we
have no good way of detecting whether
there is or isn't a variant and whether
it does or doesn't have certain effects
you know uh see earlier point about the
absurdly low quality of the tests we
have at our own disposal to even check
whether we're on the same page yeah so
someone actually asks um
in here i saw it
um
ah
your kit developed pre-omicron targeted
alpha spike maybe package insert might
say uh it didn't i looked but um but i
think that's you know the the fact that
the tests in so far as they might have
been effective um have
clearly lost a tremendous efficacy now
might well be about omicron and indeed
at one point the last couple of weeks i
think i said on air that there was a
there that some people were arguing that
this actually should be called serious
kobe 3 that it was so different um in
which case yeah you wouldn't expect the
tests to work even so far as they did
work before but but but the point is
look then that's a flaw in the test at a
different level right if you're sending
out a test it isn't applicable to the
currently circulating variant and people
aren't aware that that's a variable that
they need to pay attention to and they
need to ignore these tests or throw them
out replace them whatever it is that's
another that's still on you for sending
out these freaking tests and not a lot
allowing us to know what they even are
so
well in the case of
still on you this is private enterprise
now of course biden is now sending out
or you know the administration is now
sending out tests
small number of tests for free to people
who ask for them but these this was some
private corporation that generated these
things but it's not private enterprise
right to the extent that we have
authoritarian mandates where the federal
government is now getting between your
doctor and your pharmacist yeah i know
all that but these particular tests were
generated right the point is
okay suppose i put out a test that
doesn't test for covet but claims to
right do you think the federal
government's going to put put up with
that
why would i think they wouldn't i don't
know i mean are they even tracking all
these
all these tests are proliferating right
and it's a wide open market and like but
the point is why is it
if my doctor cannot command my
pharmacist to dispense a pharmaceutical
that is legally within his rights then
why is it that we decide well that's
free market you can send out whatever
test you want the point is we are
deciding to regulate and we are
regulating in an insane way if the
well but i i think
i think we actually agree but i i see no
reason to assume that the federal
government is in fact regulating
the particularly or watching or actually
following through on the regulations
they presumably claim to have in place
uh the rapid antigen tests that um at
least that they aren't sending out maybe
the ones that they're sending out have
some kind of
measures i don't have the i don't have
the sense that they are doing anything
right but my point is the idea that well
there's nothing that they could do about
it no there's everything that they could
do about it and they would have an
obligation to say there's nothing they
could do about it i don't think they're
doing anything of course they're not but
my point is to the extent that we are
turning civilization upside down to
prevent the spread of a virus somebody
who distributes a test that is incapable
of telling you whether you have it while
pretending that it can tell you whether
you have it is causing people to get the
virus to the extent that the virus is
deadly it's killing them that is exactly
the sort of thing that government would
be front and center speculation is for
right and so
all i'm saying is look
you've got a test if it is out of date
and that is the problem with it then
that is a place where there needs to be
an urgent alert this test is out of date
it does not contain data about whether
you don't have the current variant of
covid
yeah and i've seen i've seen no
no discussion from anywhere official
about the relative efficacy i mean early
on
when there were calls for okay we need
we had lots of testing you know when
when when it still seemed like actually
you know rapid testing um and as often
as you needed it across the population
might actually get this thing under
control so you could actually know and
you know the variants were actually a
lot more deadly than they are than the
most recent one is um
that seemed like something to be done
but i but
but not not now well i want to say one
more thing before we move on
we've seen
testing protocols designed to increase
the appearance of covid right high cycle
thresholds uh
uh used to increase the sense that covet
is ever present right
to the extent that something is using
covet as an excuse
then what is more useful than people not
being able to know they have it because
they get false negatives which appears
to be the bias of these tests
so we at least have to ask that question
right it is doing whatever whatever the
public health authority is is doing the
inverse of what it should do and tests
to give you a false negative will cause
more spread
yep this next question is a big one i
don't think i really feel like we need
to get through more questions and we
don't have very much time so um unless
you have something quick i'm going to
ask it and then ask us to just move on
instead of riff for another two minutes
no adverbs love you guys thank you for
your courage what in your opinion
constitutes effective healthcare system
greetings from bulgaria
uh i do have something quick okay we
would be much better off if we allowed
doctors
to do medicine by
trying things that seem like they are
likely to work and pooling information
on what they discover without
interfering with them that is not to say
that that is the best system but that
would be so far and away better than
what we've got that we are crazy to be
doing the opposite of it
so that does not address um anything
about the economics of healthcare
which is presumably usually when people
say healthcare system what they're
talking about is how do all the players
get paid such that the thing can
continue uh and
i do not have
um
i don't have an answer i don't know i
think you have failure modes in both
sides you've got a failure mode for
single payer and you've got a fail
failure mode for uh the free market and
we've seen both and so
i guess yeah looking for a game not at
all clear to me that those are the only
two ways to go and i just i i do not
know this landscape i will say this
there is no way
that unregulated or
minimally regulated insurance is capable
of delivering
um
is capable of delivering on the
objective insurance by its very nature
profits when it insures those who need
it least and uninsures those who need it
most and so if you've got private
insurance companies as the core of your
system for delivering health care it
won't work at the point that you've
regulated them enough to get rid of that
problem you've then invited the problems
of incompetent governance
okay one more thing
um
one thing that we do still have
uh is
multiple
um
historical traditions by which doctors
become credentialed and this is a good
thing we don't just have mds we also
have do's and we also have nds we have
you know medical doctors and we have
osteopaths and we have naturopaths and
we also have eastern traditions of
various sorts things like acupuncturists
and we also have chiropractors like you
know but but among the you know the
doctors with prescribing privileges at
least in the west we have those three
mds do's and nd's
and they all come with different biases
with different traditions with different
go-to tools that they're most likely to
pull out of their
toolkit first
and
it is
necessary
that we continue to have all three of
those and i would say better if there
were even more
but at least all three of those and i
have had um
i
have not actually had
bad luck with osteopaths or naturopaths
but i know people who have
there are certainly bad naturopaths out
there and there are certainly bad
osteopaths out there
probably everyone has had bad
experiences with mds just because mds
tend to be the types of doctors that um
you you see most and therefore you will
tend to run into incompetent or gullible
or foolish or whatever mds more often
than you run into uh incompetent or
foolish or gullible nds or do's just
because you run into them less in
general but having these different
traditions alive and well and able to
practice and having again prescribing
privileges as well and
having relationships with hospitals so
they have the full gamut of healthcare
at their disposal is absolutely
necessary because it was just md's
that's a monopoly and you know like you
know
antitrust thinking works in every domain
and that would that would be a problem
and frankly
um
all of the public policy advice at least
in the u.s uh emerges from the
only the one
system yep right
uh okay
um
recovered from covid not in a risk group
mostly just bad fever no mucus or
coughing until after i tested negative
is this just my body clearing the debris
or something else
we've had
certainly
zach and i had the experience and the
two of you who had it much less had had
less of this but also have heard from so
many people including doctors
that especially with omicron the
incredible amount of mucus afterwards
that your body is is producing um is is
truly one of the very notable things
about this about this variant and um
and i don't know why it should be
different by variant so two things one
my advisor dick alexander used to talk
about the moment at which your coughing
changed from coughing on behalf of your
pathogen as it tries to spread to new
people to coughing on your own behalf
basically clearing
uh
remnants this is so important like say
say it again or i'll say it like a cough
a cough can be one of two things and it
tends
not to be both at the same time that
tends to be a temporal trajectory well i
don't know that i don't know that you're
not doing a certain amount of
okay there was an overlap yeah period um
but at some point
at some point early in disease
progression your cough is often about
spreading the disease and therefore
you're not coughing on your behalf and
late in the trajectory after your body
has basically tackled the pathogen you
are coughing on your own behalf yes and
yet you know one of the one of the
outcomes of this insane moment that
we're all living through is that any
cough um is seen as a sign of a
plague outbreak and if you cough
if you cough anywhere out
people look at you like you're
spreading death but if you think about
it from an evolutionary point of view
the pathogen has to not only
successfully infect you it has to induce
behavior that causes you to spread it
and so damaging tissue that then
irritates you know your your trachea
such that you end up coughing
is a mechanism that is likely to happen
which means it's likely to infect those
cells one of the things that is causing
the difference
between our various reactions to this
though is almost certainly this may even
be luck of the draw
where we get infected right yeah so the
point is there's some you know did i get
a different variant than you no almost
certainly not our family probably had
one variant of this yeah we had
different reactions to it some of that
could be
varying vitamin d levels but pretty low
chance because we've been supplementing
enough probably none of us were
deficient so the point is well what does
account for the variation there's a
genetic background stuff possibly
there's what viruses you've had maybe
i've had more coronaviruses up till now
and so my immune system
you know was better able to spot this
one and you know toby's youth obviously
worked in his favor very likely
but there's also this simple question
about
the locality of your infection and then
what that tells you about what your
trajectory is going to be what the
symptoms will be and how long it will
take to clear and that also is a reason
that these vaccines kind of suck
right you're injecting something into
your arm even if it worked exactly the
way they had intended it to work it's
not where you're going to get the
infection so your immune system
your overall immune system being alerted
isn't nearly as useful as your lungs
being alerted um and anyway lots
downstream from that yep
um so zach we're close to an hour i
imagine
you're at about three minutes
okay i'm going to try to i want to get
to we just have way too many here that
we didn't get to this time even though
we started out with few so
how do you reconcile geert vandenbosch's
thesis about vaccines driving escape
variants with the fact that delta and
omicron emerged in countries with low
vaccination rates india and south africa
i think i think um
the
his response with regard to india is
that that's where there were vaccine
trials going on
specifically in the place where delta
emerged and then with regard to omicron
omicron is just so different um that um
it's it's very hard
it's not at all clear that if garrett
vandenbosch is correct which um it looks
to me like he likely is that omicron is
necessarily that
um yes i think this is a very
the problem is people you know oh you're
really saying it's the vaccine trial
that doesn't sound like very many people
the point is evolution is a much more
powerful mechanism than you think and
basically what is the difference think
about it this way what is the difference
between a vaccine trial and a serial
passage experiment right a serial
passage experiment isn't a million
ferrets it's not a thousand ferrets
right it might be dozens of ferrets
right it is a small number of
individuals in which enough evolution
takes place to be useful we know this is
true that's why we do these experiments
and so the point is a vaccine trial is
capable of doing that and i believe this
argument is compelling
at least as far as
where are the variants coming from
they're coming from selection due to the
vaccines is that the only place they
could come from not necessarily but it
is the most likely place and to the
extent that the evolution is spike based
that's why
oh boy
okay um
our former student austin says can you
outline your theory of gay please
eventually and soon you know what he'll
say austin you know you know what
happens here
um
it's a hypothesis of gay but it's a
it's a strong one
um daily average deaths are slightly
higher in top ten vast states versus
lowest ten vast states
nyt
uh cdc and hhs data that's new york
times centers for disease control and
health and human services data how is
this possible
well
you would have to go through it again
for me to
daily average deaths are slightly higher
in the top 10 vaccinated states versus
the lowest 10 vaccine states
there's a number of reasons it could be
possible and one of the possibilities is
that um you've got excess deaths
resulting
from adverse events from the vaccines
right that's a real possibility
it's noise it's also possible um yeah
slightly higher if you know if that's
not significant in um
in any real sense then
it doesn't mean anything not that if it
was slightly lower uh we wouldn't they
wouldn't be crowing about it yep um but
yeah you'd want to know if it's actually
different could be ade i don't know
whether these are corrected for the
percentage of the population
that's vaccinated who knows
yeah oh no
does it say per capita
no but top 10 vast states versus lowest
10 vaccinations well then it's a very
very rough measure so
it could be a lot of things including
some very bad ones yep
okay let us
um let us end with this question which
is a really good one and we should
probably spend a whole episode on it but
um but we won't let's just take a first
pass at
why should we trust you i am a loyal
listener and love you guys but when i
refer you guys to my friends etc i'm
asked that question
why should we trust you
i think this is an excellent question
yeah it's a good question
and
um yeah just
first first pass
we tell you
why we think what we think
and we tell you when we think we've been
wrong
we correct ourselves
and uh we don't just error correct
privately but we are correct publicly
when it's when it's big enough to to
warrant it you know they've been a
little little
movement here and there on on various
things
we of course put out so much content
that doesn't mean that everyone will run
into everything that we say but um we
make a point of that that is um that is
central to us
being public in the world is that if we
say something that we
come to understand differently later
either because
um our analysis is wrong or because
there is new data in there for the
situation has changed we um we will
change our position
and um
and we're also
um you know the opposite of
uh benefiting from our stance
uh so
you know the the one of the common
things that is said
of those of us who are dissenters to use
the language of tablet magazine is that
we are grifters which suggests profiting
uh from a position that you might not
even really hold and uh you know we are
we are doing quite the opposite we were
when we started the podcast
we quickly got an audience and were
quickly came to be making a nice income
uh through youtube from
speaking what we saw as truth about um
the pandemic and we weren't running
afoul except for lab leak we weren't
running a foul of the dominant
narratives for a while
and um when we started to uh we got um
demonetized and we um you know
lost access to a number of the
outlets and places where we we had
previously been able to publish things
and speak
and it would have been much easier
to just either stop talking about it or
to change our tune
and
the fact is
that
both of us would rather be talking about
other things
right this isn't this isn't what we what
we want to be talking about i'd much
rather be talking about rat bats
um
but here we are because it feels damned
important
and uh and
and we
hear from so many people um
that they are grateful to have a source
that does error correct and does
does come with some
humility but also confidence that what
our
what our values are what our scientific
backgrounds are combine into a model
that actually has over and over and over
again
predicted accurately what is to come
so i want to refine some of what you
said okay
and take a different tack
the fact is
a we're not telling you to trust us but
predictive power ought to tell you
whether or not we are trustworthy but
trustworthy also means a couple
different things
right
um
there are people that i trust
when i say that i'm talking about
ethically i am not talking about their
judgment i don't trust anybody's
judgment completely including my own
right the fact is we all have incomplete
data we all make errors in analyzing it
and the question is what do you do when
you make an error right that is the
indication and whether you're good at
this game or not good at this game can
be read in your ability to predict
things that are not known
and the question of how far ahead you
can predict them right those two things
are a good indication and a single
prediction doesn't tell you anything but
a track record does so
you can
decide for yourself but if you look back
at all of the things that we have said
and you look at how they have
uh
fared over the course of the pandemic
you will see hey we have a hell of a
track record right the thing i feel
least good about is masks which i
thought were likely to work and i think
i was too slow to recognize that the
evidence suggested they were actually
ineffective cloth masks especially yeah
and but and this is something that we've
said this correction several times
several different times right um i do
not you know
there's this this grifter thing which i
detest as an attack because i know and
anybody who knows us well knows that we
are not motivated by money
i do not want to use as a litmus test
did you come out ahead or not no we
can't that's not the right limit we
can't dictate whether or not we will
come out ahead or not in the end the
point is it wouldn't change what we're
saying at all and it didn't the fact is
when youtube demonetized us it knocked
out more than half of our family income
and they gave us a path back and we said
no
right we continue to do what we do and
so
that tells you right if that results in
people thinking that we're worth
listening to and
finding some way to support us
great that's good that's the way it
should work but it's not why we did it
right we did it because it was the right
thing to do and
that's really the reason that you you
should trust us if you do and you
shouldn't take our word for it you
should go back and look and you know for
your friends who don't know whether they
can trust us
the point is
give it time right
listen in and see whether or not it
results in you being ahead of the curve
and frankly
we will never know the people who have
been listening to us right would have
been supplementing vitamin d they would
have been taking advantage of the
outdoor environment there are so many
different ways in which they might have
been materially healthier and happier
and better connected and better informed
and not been so damn surprised by the
failure of all of the things that
haven't worked and the point is
that's probably why you're tuning in
right
you want to know more about what's
coming than other people because they're
misinformed and you don't want to be
let me add one more thing i'm reminded
of what
how i used to begin every uh program
every academic program at evergreen when
i was a professor there um which is the
very first day of class
i would say
uh don't trust me
i haven't earned it yet yeah i have a
degree and i'll be writing your
narrative evaluations and i've written
the curriculum and all of this like you
know i am i am at the moment the
authority standing in front of the room
and i
believe that i have things that i can
teach you and that you will end up uh
more wise and able to solve problems for
yourself
as a result of being in this room with
me for the next 10 20 or 30 weeks or in
the field or wherever
but don't take my word for it for god's
sake and don't take the word of the
university of michigan who awarded me
this degree or the evergreen hiring
committee that hired me
which are the ways by which i got to be
in front of you don't don't trust any of
those people
you watch and you engage and you
question and
you you know you posit the hard
questions and you also observe
when over time they get it right i don't
get it right and that's that track
record of predictions that were risky
and turned out to be right
that provides a basis for trust yeah and
i would also say you you mentioned in in
your answer there
personally what i do when i'm trying to
figure out whether or not somebody is
for real right i watch very carefully
how they deal with questions that they
do not know are coming
right somebody who has a pretty slick
story and sounds really good and you're
not in a position basically to evaluate
what they're saying because it's not
your area right that falls apart if they
are faced with difficult questions right
they will not be able to answer them
compellingly and they will resort to you
know manipulative tricks and things like
that if somebody is capable you know if
they say hey here's a here's a thesis
you haven't heard
it says some radical things um but
here's why you ought to
put stock in it and then they're faced
with questions and they field them well
it's like well now i know something
that's that's a model with depth and if
they don't field them well i say well i
don't know what that was but yeah now
you you
you should not trust people or outfits
um that are unwilling to to field
questions that they don't see coming and
you know there's lots of reasons in
particular moments that there's no time
q and a's are unwieldy whatever um
but
if if people never
think in front of you if they never let
you see them actually wrestle with ideas
that they claim to hold dear
in front of you um
that suggests that either they're
they've accepted some ideology that's
pat and they themselves don't understand
it or that they are obscuring something
that's inconsistent just below the
surface i imagine there are more
explanations than that but those are two
likely ones if people are unwilling to
do any kind of a live fire
exercise yep
all right i think that was a good place
to end
um we will i believe be back the normal
time um next week we may be
transitioning into doing late friday
things in the future but for next week
we'll be here at
uh 12 30 p.m saturday pacific time
saturday
and
i guess the um on my patreon this sunday
is the private q a um so if you liked
this you'll probably like that consider
joining us when we leave them up too so
if you can't join us live um it remains
up and you can look at the chat too
and anything else before we sign off i
think that's it all right be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you